[Music]
the ceo posting the crying selfie
crying selfie after layoffs to show
exactly normal people do
yeah dude the ceo of hyper social it's a
great name it's a [ __ ] great name
which specializes in services like
optimizing linkedin both
[ __ ] yeah face criticism for making the
layoffs about himself but said he simply
wanted to share his journey i should
have started a crypto company that's
what he's thinking
[Laughter]
i was dying i forgot
who or what i was watching but it was
someone
being critical of crypto they're
basically pointing out that so many of
the voices like champion and crypto or
just like young dudes who have never
actually like really achieved any wealth
just like these 21 year olds in college
that made a [ __ ] bag off of
whatever [ __ ] coin and they're like nah
dude the future is in the blockchain you
sure man yeah okay
all right
now you got it
this will be the most vulnerable thing
i'll ever share [ __ ] dude days like
today
i wish i was a business owner that was
only money driven and i didn't care oh
[Music]
go
and didn't care
who he hurt along the way sometimes i
wish i wasn't such a good person
it's so hard
just carrying around the weight
being such a good guy the lawsuit that's
coming from this must be so heavy i just
want people to see that not every ceo
out there is cold-hearted and doesn't
care when she he slash he have to lay
people off i'm sure there are hundreds
and thousands of other like just like me
yeah but not quite as good as me though
not quite as successful i'm also the one
with the biggest hard one and i had to
optimize linkedin okay and i have the
biggest dick too it's so hard being so
nice and having movie stroke like
it's so tough like having this long
thick dick and awesome
my massive [ __ ] it's two things it's
heavy on two sides it pulls me down
because the dick is so big and then the
weight of everyone's feelings also just
makes me feel so heavy it's like i care
about everyone and every girl wants to
[ __ ] me and i just want to [ __ ] them
back and i can't [ __ ] them all so
because i'm caring so hard about other
people
i'm too busy being sad
because i can't [ __ ] the wall i had to
start a company to get them paid because
i want women to make money are your
linkedin posts not reaching enough
people
well i got the solution for you
he performed one of the layoffs and his
quote girlfriend slash business partner
laid off the other employee while he
watched oh he's a freak
cocking a layoff
he is a freak i love watching you do
this
she's like so we're gonna have to let
you go
[Music]
you little minks yeah you're not i'm
sorry you're just you know the the
the whole landscape has shifted and uh
you know our runway is we gotta we gotta
be careful we're not we don't have
enough money
you'll still have insurance
for the next few months and we'll give
you a small severance
and we're going to send your name and
linkedin profile out to other companies
but
as of today we're taking your
uh laptop this company property
[Laughter]
you will not be able to file for
employees like
employees like does he need to be here
this is making me feel so weird
yeah he's just there in person but he's
on a zoom call
and his face is not visible it's just
the audio
oh
i don't understand i've been with you
guys for four years and
you and
and you just just like this oh yeah
you're gone
[Laughter]
you're out
[Laughter]
go
[Laughter]
quote i was just sitting here at my desk
just kind of crying i guess and decided
to make the po yep
because i have seen a lot of link on
linkedin recently of how awful business
owners and ceos are for laying off their
employees that they're laying off
oh my god dude don't lay me off i see a
[ __ ] punk about it dude when i got
laid off from my call center job i i've
talked about this before but the
experience was so
hilarious and surreal they took all like
150 or 200 of us just on our floor alone
and stuffed us into what i think was
an office of people who probably had
been laid off a couple weeks before us
okay then this [ __ ]
gets up they have a [ __ ] they rent a pa
system so he can talk to everyone he
grabs the microphone and he just like in
30 seconds
so uh
yeah given uh given the merger here uh
we've decided to uh shut down the la
office uh if you have any questions you
can speak to your supervisor goodbye uh
he kind of like hung out for a minute
and then he let other people field
questions he tried to sneak out of there
early and i didn't see him but
simultaneously i'm like oh i gotta take
a piss
so i leave
i go take a piss he sneaks in after me
sometimes i wish i'd go back to that
moment and just stand in the doorway of
the bathroom and be like
look at me
why'd you fire me yeah
why yeah
oh i'm not good enough for you yeah oh
that's cool dude so you and my mom
yeah no that's cool man you guys talk to
each other come on why did you fire me
you have to pee did you pee you have to
pee did you pee yeah just
he's peeing at the urinal you just go
right up to the back of his head why'd
you fire me yeah the way he maneuvered
around me was like he was trying to get
through me he would have walked like if
he could split my body just like
but could you imagine if i just let him
go and then as soon as i hear his
belt buckle undone i'm like hey he's in
here
[Laughter]
yeah are you pooping yeah yeah
are you pooping good because we're gonna
[ __ ] jump you
just stand him up start sucking him in
the stomach come on [ __ ] man
this is good following the criticism
this week
walaike waleki wallake
admitted he thought the photo was
cringeworthy as well self-aware king yep
for all the negative attention he
received
while lake said he was heartened to see
other entrepreneurs reply saying they
were interested in potentially hiring
the laid off employees damn so it really
is he's not that's funny because he's
like yeah sure i was a little cringe but
guess what those people got hired
because of that so actually i'm the hero
here yeah
it's like [ __ ]
yeah
and see i was the saddest and i have the
biggest dick
that's really really funny what that
whole thing
just him yeah yeah
are self-aware king yeah
you